hence Alexi reznikov for joining us
again today we value your presence and
we are looking forward to hearing your
thoughts here shortly please allow me
now to introduce Secretary of Defense
Lloyd Austin to deliver opening remarks
Mr secretary
thanks secretary hello everyone and
thanks for joining us virtually from
time zones
around the world
and welcome to the 12th meeting of the
Ukraine defense contact group it's great
to see everyone again
as Ukraine advances its fight against
Russian Invaders
the members of this contact group Stand
United
since this group met last month the
United States has committed an
additional 1.8 billion dollars in
security assistance to Ukraine
that includes a recent package of 375
million dollars with
equipment such as high Mars ammunition
anti-tank systems
and laser-guided Rockets
we're also providing key combat enablers
such as
heavy equipment transport
in armored bridging systems
and in our latest
Ukraine security assistance initiative
package
the United States funded additional air
defense systems and munitions
that package also includes equipment
that will integrate Ukraine's Legacy air
defense systems
with air defense launchers missiles and
Radars from members of this contact
group
we're also providing more 155 millimeter
artillery rounds as well as more
training maintenance and sustainment
we're focused on contributions that make
a real difference difference in real
time
yet the United States is also committed
to standing with Ukraine for the Long
Haul
and so are the countries that have
gathered here today
we've been working in lockstep with all
of you to get Ukraine's Defenders what
they need when they need it
several contact group members have made
important announcements recently
Germany pledged to provide Ukraine with
more leopard tanks ammunition
combat drones and more
in a package worth nearly three billion
dollars
and that reflects Germany's drive to
meet Ukraine's near near-term needs and
Germany's investment for the Long Haul
Denmark also announced a significant new
package
it includes air defense support and
combat enablers such as mine clearing
Vehicles mobile field Bridges
and Recovery vehicles
France also has committed more light
tanks and armored vehicles
all of these donations respond to
Ukraine's top priority requirements and
reflect the sustained resolve of this
contact group
together contact group members have
ensured that Ukrainian soldiers
have the training that they need
we've trained nine
motorized and mechanized brigades and
continue to execute collective training
for Ukrainian combat units
earlier this month
31 M1 Abrams training tanks from the
United States arrived at grafenwir in
Germany
and last week President Biden announced
that the United States will support a
joint effort with our allies and
partners to train Ukrainian pilots on
fourth generation aircraft including
f-16s
now we hope this training will begin in
the coming weeks
this will further strengthen and improve
the capabilities of the Ukrainian Air
Force in the long term
and it will complement our short-term
and median medium-term security
agreements
this new joint effort sends a powerful
message about our Unity
in our long-term commitment to Ukraine's
self-defense
and it again shows our shared
determination to ensure that a sovereign
and secure Ukraine can deter any future
aggression and defend itself against
future attacks
you can see that commitment in our work
on the most important capability that
this contact group is now providing
ground-based air defense systems
those crucial systems are protecting
Ukraine skies and civilian
infrastructure from Russia's assault
and we continue to deliver much needed
ammunition
in total the contact group has committed
nearly 65 billion dollars in security
assistance
now Putin was hoping that our resolve
would fade
and he was betting that our Unity would
crack
instead we remain as United as ever
in the whole world can see it now
everyone here knows that the what the
ukrainians are up against
Russia has renewed its shocking and
shameful barrage of missile attacks that
threaten innocent Ukrainian civilians
including Hypersonic missiles aimed at
Key
but this contact group continues to
strengthen Ukraine's air defenses and
save innocent lives
ukrainians now have the Patriot air
defense system on their side
provided by the United States Germany
and the Netherlands
and Ukraine has been shooting down
Russian missiles with precision and
skill
the Patriots saves lives
and so do air defense systems like Irish
tea and they Sans that this group has
also delivered
we've helped Ukraine defend disguise and
we won't let up
Russia has failed to dominate
Ukrainian airspace
and that's why air defense capabilities
will again be a major focus of our
discussions today
now let me take just a moment to preview
more of today's agenda
as always we're joined by our good
friend Alexi reznikov and his team and
Alexi thanks for taking the time to
brief us on Ukraine's priority needs for
the fight ahead
then the commanders of U.S European
command and security assistance group
Ukraine will brief us on Ukraine's near
near-term requirements
and we will discuss ways to further
accelerate industrial production for
critical systems
we're going to have to dig deeper
and we're going to have to continue to
look for create creative ways to boost
our industrial capability
mistakes are high but the cause is just
and our will is strong
and we will continue to stand up for
Ukraine's Sovereign right to live in
Freedom we'll continue to stand up for
an open world of rules and rights
and will stand up for free in Sovereign
Ukraine for as long as it takes
and with that I'll pause for a moment
and uh allow our friends in the media to
depart